good to see you guys
you know you guys are the first couple
both nominated in the same year since
2017 when tim and faith were nominated
you two met writing a song for tim what
a full circle moment i know i mean i
would never compare us to them because
it's tim and faith but
yeah it's so cool what does the
recognition tonight mean to you
well it just feels like we're getting to
do the acms for real again because you
know the last two years have been in
covid so it's nice to be back in vegas
and yeah it's going to be fun the
stadium is beautiful it's big
so it's going to be a first time for
everything on this one now you guys have
had such success with chasing after you
grammy nominations how do you top a song
like this are you working on the next
one already
well man made a really awesome album
that comes out in a couple weeks so i
would say that is the good answer maybe
we'll do another duet someday but he he
actually is all over my album like he's
singing and writing on all the songs so
it kind of feels like in any capacity
we're going to be collaborating no
matter what and you know we're married
and have a child so
lots of collaborations all around yeah
humble quest finally here how does it
feel
good it's weird to be in album release
month already but um it's been a long
time coming the record's been done for a
while so i'm just ready to like give
birth to it
speaking of giving birth how is hayes
doing because i hear that you have a
song for him on the new record yeah he
uh my song hummingbird is about my son
and he's doing good he's about to be two
and he's got his first pair of cowboy
boots this week
so he's feeling sassy um
no he's precious he's honestly the
sweetest kid like i don't know how he
got so lucky with such a sweet baby but
he is and i know i've seen videos before
of him singing and dancing is he really
embracing that musical life with his
parents
he just likes animals he likes the
animals and all the animals that's it
just the animals yeah i don't think he's
interested in our music he just wants to
like watch national geographic oh my god
now will he come on tour you just
announced you're going back on the road
yeah um i kind of always pictured being
able to be a mother and an artist and
not have to like wait on either so he's
gonna be
my co-pilot on this tour and he's he's
pretty adaptable to like tour already so
he's he's gonna have fun have you guys
already baby proofed the bus you know
what to do with that
still working on it but it's getting
there it's a work in progress but he
loves it like it it's probably like a
field trip for him